complexity and inquiry evaluation
and today is going to be a shorter day
than others will finish by around noon
or so the expectation was that by the
afternoon of the fifth date typically
people you know may take off to the
airport or something so we uh
in the afternoon
and uh
um yeah so the the topic of the last day
is going to be incremental maintenance
it's going to be given by xiaohu
she is
technically an assistant professor at
the University of Waterloo but her visa
is your situation has run into a bit
open now
we don't quite now yet anyways
um
yeah so I'll give the mike to CL
please go ahead
hello everyone I'm here again but today
I'm talking about incremental view
maintenance uh I'm afraid that I may not
be the best person to talk about this
topic because there are so many experts
in the audience
um but I'm very interested in this topic
and I started working on this uh problem
in the last two years so today I would
like to share some interesting results
in recent papers and hope to give you
some idea about the group discussion
okay
um
so let's have a quick review of the
problem definition uh don't you know
give us a very nice talk in the boot
camp so this slides just from okay from
his talk uh the basic problem is that
given a query and a database we want to
deliver the query answers okay as soon
as possible to the user and this problem
becomes more challenging when the
database is dynamic okay well the tuples
can be inserted and deleted then how to
compute the or maintain the query
answers efficiently and instead of
computing everything from scratch after
every update the idea is how to utilize
the previous query answers to build the
new cover answers okay
uh the common approach is to build a
data structure okay by exploring the
queries information of the query
structure as well as the statistics of
the database okay so that's the query
answers can be enumerated from this data
structure with uh with found data delay
okay so the name is the upper bound on
the time between the start of the
enumeration and the receiving the first
answer is also upper bound on the
waiting time between every consecutive
pair of answers as well as the receiving
the last answer and the end of the
enumeration process
there are three important performance
metrics for the data structure uh one is
the previous pre-processing time okay to
build the data structure and also the
update time okay to update the data
structure when the top point is inserted
or deleted uh okay that is the delay for
the enumeration process
in dance talk uh Hey focus on the
trade-off between these three uh
important measurements the
pre-processing time the update time and
the delay
but in today's talk I will focus on the
constant delay enumeration okay the
constants means that okay the user only
needs to wait a constant time before
receiving the first answer as well as
the the waiting time for receiving the
last answer okay if the query is just a
booty inquiry the the constant delay
means that the answering time is just a
constant okay the constant can depends
on the size of the query uh the number
of relations and the number of
attributes
so here we focus on the pre-processing
time and uptime update time for this
data structure
okay
so the goal is not to Output the Delta
the goal is to build the data structure
where you can get the entire
view that's a good point yeah I plan to
distinguish a full enumeration the Delhi
inversion
so the user can request the full results
okay the QD or only the Delta results
the Delta result means the new result
induced by the inserted up or the other
result will disappear by the by the
decision of one table okay
um so this problem in general is very
hard we learned from that uh the update
time for General queries is at least the
routine
and a data structure with constant
update time is only possible it's only
possible if the query is q hierarchical
um for example we have two tables R1 a b
and r2bc if we want all attributes to be
outputted then the query secure
hierarchical but if we are only
interested in the attribute ANC in
output then this query is non-q
hierarchical
this is also a landscape okay from dance
talk
um if we just focus on the constant data
enumeration so this uh this is the
overview of the results that can be
achieved for uh pre-processing time and
update time okay for different class of
queries
you can see in the middle is the Q
hierarchical query and we we can achieve
a data structure that can be built in
linear pre-processing time and updated
in consonant time
for constant delay enumeration but for
all other queries we need to pay
much more costs
okay
there are some observations okay the
first one is that the class of cure
hierarchical query is still very small
okay sitting in the middle of the whole
picture and the second observation is
that the upper bound down the update
time is not a very satisfactory uh yeah
if you just look at the Q hierarchical
we can hope for constant but for free
class query this is linear and the
seminar for hieraraku and the triangle
drawing as well as the general
conjunctive curve
so there's a still a huge gap between
okay the queue hierarchical and the
non-q hierarchical and even I don't know
whether this is the
best we can do yeah
um
the third observation is that the
negative result of the harness result we
just talked about it only holds for the
worst case update sequence the worst
case means that you can actually
construct the update sequence
um but
um in the real world application most
update sequence are not so bad instead
they display some nice property or
patterns okay the question is can we
design better algorithm by exploring the
information of the update sequence if we
know have more information about the
update sequence can we have a better
analysis
uh so in today's talk I will first focus
on the full enumeration for full
conjunctive query so this is the class
of query okay
in the second part I will move to a
conjunctive query with aggregations
if we still have time I plan to go to
the Delhi information but this part okay
it's optional okay
um yeah I will go through some results
in the in the recent papers okay at
least there
uh now I will have a quick review of the
background knowledge so the definition
of conjunctive query I usually
interviewed as the join project query so
you have a bunch of relations in the
body of the query and also the set of
attributes they are defined on
um the output attribute is the subset of
attributes that appear in the body of
the of the query and we also call it a
full drawing if every attribute appear
in the body also appears as the output
attribute
and when attribute is empty this is a
special Boolean query which only uh
outputs true or false indicating whether
there exists a joint results in the body
of the of this current
um
here are some examples oh the first one
is the Simon's triangle joint we want to
Output all the
triangles in in the query and the second
one is
lens for path but we're only interested
in the first four attributes okay and
the last one is is also to is the
Boolean query determine whether there
exists a length will pass okay
uh
uh before we talk about upper bounds
yeah self joint doesn't know
yeah make a difference uh but this is a
good passion for lower ball yeah
I think
it's great for discussion yeah
so uh so what is the frequent story
um there are many different definitions
here I just introduced one based on the
drawing tree okay
um
I think you have
that is in the previous talk okay let me
just quickly uh go through this uh joint
tray is the trade structure such that
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between the relations and the notes okay
so if suppose this is the conjunction
query and we will have R1 R2 r3r4 as the
nodes of the tree okay and for every
attribute all the notes containing this
attributes forms the collective summary
you can check for example this X2
R1 are connected for X3
r2r3 are Galaxy X4 r3r4 are connected
okay
uh there's another condition for free
connects
okay uh this says there are no output
non-output attributes appears above the
topmost node of of any output attribute
okay this is a little bit messy here so
we just consider the topmost node of any
output at any attribute then it says
that the topmost node of any non-output
attribute should not be the ancestor of
any uh the topmost node for any output
attribute let me show some example
uh here
uh X5 is not output attribute the
topmost node it appears is R4 for
example X1 is the output attribute and
the topmost node it appears is R1 here
R4 is the ancestor of R1 so this is not
available
the connectivity is not satisfied
actually appears in R3 and R2 and we are
not connected
is it the property of the query or
property of the tree it is that there
should exist a one joint tree with this
property yes
yeah you can interpret uh this as R1
r2r3 this collateral subject including
this in this root forms a convex of this
tree here
so sorry so which one is the output
attribute here
is
so
those are the output attributes it does
not appear X5 is the now output
attribute so if I if you turn around
that chain then it's good if you throw
it upside down exactly so the
joint Trace is not unique yeah
yeah it's not just unique it depends on
how you draw it I suppose you are a
human orientation on the edges
you can also put R3 as the root you know
just
so I might be even running around but is
there an equivalent definition saying
that you can add one more atom
containing certainly active yes
yeah equivalent
so what is the precise one can you
remind us uh uh the the
that definition says okay the first of
the query should be or cyclic so there
exists a joint tree and uh
if you add another relation C are out
containing all the output attributes
with the queue this is still at another
relation there's the the result your
query is still a cyclic
so inside the union you should have oh
yeah for this node will be restart but I
just want to see if you add another
relation to this to this uh current yeah
to the body of the curry so here if you
add another relation with X1 X2 X3 X4
yeah yeah you need to completely
restructure that tree to make it I'm
assuming you have already you need
another
where you collapse some of the notes of
the original tree
now it's extremely to keeps and you it's
become a star no yeah exactly you have a
big ass out x y x 2 x 3 x 4 and you have
R1 R2
R3 yeah
wait okay we will talk about the
frequency query in a dynamic setting we
need a more complicated uh
joint tree okay now we generalize the
previous joint trade by introducing the
generalized relation so the general
relation can be a proper subside of any
original relation about something okay
it is still a trade structure and yeah
the first three completion are almost
the same
the fourth one is that generalize the
relation appear above any original
relations
in this example X3 is a generalized
relation okay it could be the projection
of R2 or R3 okay and it appears of any
original relation industry
uh
there's another condition set that for
every generalized relation and it's a
child
this attribute should be completely
contained by the children
there are different definition of
Journalism joint
um I will talk about them later but this
one will be used in our analysis okay
so it says for for e and each of its
children yeah each of these children
every children so you can imagine on Top
This is essentially a kill hierarchy
important notion here is the height of
the joint tree
okay the height of this generalized
joint tray is the maximum number of
original relations on any two root path
okay
for this example any Leaf to root path
the number of original relations is just
a two so this generalized joint has
hydrogen
foreign
nice property about the general as a
jointry uh the first one is okay how to
connect these two Q hiraku curries
um so okay Q hiroko is a very special
class of queries that's for every
attribute pair of attributes X1 X2 uh
okay uh ex is the set of relations
containing x to the X so there's some
hierarchy between uh
the set of relations continues okay and
more importantly if one attribute is an
output attribute and this e x y is a
true subset proper subset of ex2 then X2
should also be output attributes
important observation is that
okay secure hierarchical if and only if
it has a height one generalizer joint
Let me Give an example so
so for this example we can I can give
you some intuition here so we can build
some uh Tree on the structure on the
attributes based on this hierarchy okay
relation
and if you can look at the the height
one channel as a joint tree you can have
some correspondence between this one
because you can just put
or the nose from the root to this one
and to augment this node then you will
get the the corresponding node in a
generalized search
and for this one if you check every leaf
to path uh root test there's exactly one
original relation so
actually you give that uh
oh yeah so
um so that's that's what what we can get
from the hierarchy means that if uh if
uh the EX3 is a subset of ex2 you just
add X2 as the parent of X3
okay so that's the background knowledge
now we are ready to talk about
enumeration for full conjunctive colors
um in the literature the framework
change propagation is the traditional
candle uh to handle the
to handle the problem and each query
plan can be represented as a tree such
that okay sorry such that every original
relation is a leaf of this tree and each
internode is an operator for example for
the uh for this query plan it will
materialize The Joint result between R
to R3 as a view V1 and then further
materialize R1 join V1 as V2 and also
for example here this is a projection
operator it will materialize V3 as the
projection of rf1 attribute X4 and later
okay it will further materialize the
join between V2 and V3 as another view
if there is an update in the original
relation it will propagate to the root
okay
um since we have modularized we voice
the query result okay of this
of this conjunctive query so the full
and the Delta enumeration are trivial
because you just need to investigate the
rules node but
materialize this
views is very cost
ly for example uh the view V1 can be as
large as the size R2 times R3 because
there could be a calcium product
uh also the update cost can be super New
Year for example if we want to update
the V2 okay decide the the update time
is also uh super linear
and all this uh expensive cost
are caused by the join operator because
you yeah keep joining those wheels so
this will increase some yeah yeah
stripping in their costumes
the basic idea of this line of work is
to
replace the joint operator with the semi
joint Then followed by a projection
operator
so it will introduce two views here one
is for projection and the other four
semi semi semi joint for this example
okay
we first have the semi drawing view as
the original relation then we need to
pass some information from the bottom to
the up so which information we need to
pass which is exactly the projection of
R1 on X2 X2 is the joint attribute
between R1 and R2
so we also do this for R4 we first
materialize R4 as as the semi joint and
then we will do bottom up with just the
pasta projection to the parent okay
then when we build the semi drawing for
R2 we we need to combine the information
between R2 and the projection from R1 so
this is the semi join which is R2 semi
join VPR one
okay after we merge the information we
need to further pass the information
upward so we need the first another
projection on Accessory so which is the
joint attribute between R2 and X3
similar
okay as the last at the top note we just
do a
intersection between the projection view
from R2 and R3
you know
so
this example when we have a formal
definition so for the projection view
it's just a projection of the semi joint
view on the common attributes between
this node and its parent okay and for
the semi semi join view if this is a
knee flow the semi joint view which is
just the relations itself
but if it is an internal node the semi
join view okay for for the original node
for example the R2 is just the R2 semi
joint a set of projection view from his
children okay and if it is uh
generalized node then the semi-joint
view is just the intersection of a set
of projection views
okay
it's not a shop this is not the exchange
population this is like a whole yeah
because yeah we we want to change
propagation without joints
no but what you are describing is not
yet the the Delta complications it's
just the full in immersion yeah
so a good observation is that both semi
joint and the projection are efficient
to to update okay for example for the
semi drawing the the uh the size of the
result will always bounded by the R1 uh
the first relation and so we can use
bounded memory
for materialization and also each update
in R2 will cause at most n changes in
the result so we will have a bounded
maintenance maintenance cost
um and also for projection uh we know
that the result of the projection is at
most the input size so we will have
Bound in the memory for materialization
and also each update can cause at most
one changing the result so we will get a
constant update time guarantee okay
now I will show how to maintain this
projection View and the semi drawing
view okay
um to do that we need some additional
counters
um let me use this example to illustrate
that so for the for this semi-drone view
which is exactly R1 we have this
projection view on of the projection on
x2 we also maintain some counter okay
which simply just count how many tuples
from R1 with the specific joint value
okay whether it's two there are two
tables okay so we just
store to here and they are one table
with values three here so we just okay
let's do over here this is quite simple
just accounting okay and the one we have
the counter for the semi-drone view okay
um suppose this is an internal node with
key children okay we just maintain the
number of children such that the
projection of this Tuple is is valid
means that this exists in a projection
view okay let me uh industry in this
example uh this node will only have one
child here so the value of the city is
just a zero or one okay if you just look
at this this Tuple one two okay we
search whether one exists in a
projection view it does not exist so
this value is zero what is it true and
two research whether two exists in a
projection view yes okay there is one so
for this EX for this note this CT value
is just a zero one okay
watch out here
um with these two counters we can
efficiently maintain the the update okay
if we uh have been updated from the
original relation re okay see R2 and we
want to update the semi joint view it
only takes constant time
okay and if we have have update from the
semi drawing views and then we want to
update the projection view okay this is
also
a patient is also easy because we just
need to change the the city value here
but if we want
to update from this projection view to
its parents semi joint View
we will get into trouble because
you will have for example in this case
if all the tuples have the same
X2 value then you may
cause linear updates okay in the system
view if you just change these two to
some other okay this choice is deleted
or something uh it's another value
inserted then you have to change this
many counters in this table
so this is the worst case analysis here
is here later we will see how to do
better
um
so there's a big run example but I think
if you don't have question about the
previous slides the this run example
will become trivial okay we just build
this
I just want to say that even those
tuples have uh CT value 0 means that
they should not exist in a semi uh semi
view semi-joint view with just the keep
it here okay and I'll use different
colors
and if we want to do insertion this is
also quite straightforward we first
insert this Tuple to the original
relation and then we need to propagate
the update to the uh to the projection
projection view okay
uh then we need to update every
couple in in the semi R2 semi join R2
with the same value one here and later
we need to uh active propagate the
projection view corresponding at last
we need to uh as okay there are some new
tuples appear in the projection view
then we need to change the city value
here so the two here means how many
children knows such that one appears in
their projection Wheels
yeah so I'm wondering what these conkers
couldn't you just have a single counter
purchase think attribute value and then
they always point to that same field
and then like let's say you know all the
the ones that have the same X2 yeah
let's say if x two equal to one they
just point to a single memory cell that
has the counter for X2
and then you just set that one to one or
zero depending on if it exists in the
child
uh yes you can also do that
uh
missing something
you can get rid of
um no if for example here is the one two
one two and one for which will be
updated with the insertion yeah because
they have different values
x-rays
yeah I was just thinking because you
don't need dx3 until the next level but
then you need to still connect because
yeah for National level we want to store
X right here
how do they count zeros get generated
the roads that have ct0 yeah
uh okay uh because the The semi-joint
View are two is the semi joint between
R2 and a bunch of projection wheels so
if you don't look at the city value here
this is exactly the table for R2 so you
just keep it there yeah just to keep it
there yeah yeah
but it's not affecting any of the
analysis yeah
okay thanks yeah I want to understand
the semantic of the account so my mental
model for IBM has been that um
we keep so music in population yeah and
then give it a one if it's in the
relation and zero otherwise then the
semi ring from the Indians
and then this um uh semi-joint reduction
algorithms will become a variable
elimination
calibrate the uh the 3D competition the
jointry and so
um discount is effectively when you
remove or add something from the
children or you cannot update the view
which is an application query on top of
children right so what is the semantic
of this application query is it just a
you know join becomes some product
I think it's just a boring
for example exist or not so is it just
uh okay so you are not over counting
collapse back to either
one we don't do
it
so there's a counter I'm sorry
yeah the county here just to represent
whether it exists or not yes so two
means that this will exist in both
projections yes and this one only means
okay it is
let's switch it up
so the
uh the duration will will be similar so
I think
and yeah when we have the full
enumeration this is not it's not hard
because uh key observation is that the
the information stored in a semi joint
view is exactly the
uh local joint resulting in a sub tree
rooted at this node
yeah
yeah okay
then we know that if we look at the root
of this root of this tree okay uh the
semi drawing view is exactly the joint
result the projection of the join
results on this uh up on this attribute
so uh yeah
so we only need to retrieve the query
result for each Tuple in in the
semi-joint view of this root node okay
in the top down manner
this is oh this is not a
very okay so suppose we have a type of T
here which is in attribute 3 then we
just use the projection of this Tuple to
probe the semi joint wheel in R2 suppose
we found some top 40 Prime and then we
further use the projection of T Prime on
attribute X2 to further probe the upper
the semi joint view of R1
then you can you can get the result yeah
uh okay I also have a example here
suppose we are interested in this uh
Tuple one in the in the semi joint view
we want to enumerate the
Crown results participated by uh by one
then we just go to the uh semi-joint
view of R2 and found the Tuple with one
one yeah
and then go down find the
the value with uh with the same value Y
in X2 so we get one one and four one
okay similarly we probe the uh this
right sub tree and we will further get
two more uh results
if uh CT is smaller than the number of
children how do we know which child to
grow they won't appear in the cloud
result we don't need to the column yeah
names will tell us yeah okay the counter
will tell you whether this is
foreign
do you want to have a break here
um
why didn't you put three or three
uh R3 okay actually you can just do
independent and you just the probe one
here and you will get one two
so uh this one and the four one is
already the result we get from the left
subtree actually you can interpret as
the calcium product between these two
trees
can you have more results coming from
more results
uh if you probe one you will check all
the tuples with the value one here and
also the safety value should be one yeah
so we'll get one too
so we will stop here because uh the R4
only contains output attribute X4 X4 is
also already covered by the X R3 so we
will just stop here yeah
so
uh I think I will stop here and I hope
you have a basic understanding of the
algorithm and later we will as well as
the worst case uh running time update
time and okay when we attack we will
consider the instance dependent analysis
of the of the algorithm okay
all right thank you
[Applause]
took up five minutes